okay so yeah i'll be speaking about
georta tool the tool that is used to
analyze spatially resolved
transcriptomics the
method that was uh
named the method of the year by nature
um
well
it was a great breakthrough when
a single cell was developed compared to
bug dna it allowed us to
specifically study separate cells
but when we
analyze data using single cell we end up
with something like this
just uh
cells in an artificial dimensions in
this case it's umap but we never really
know where exactly in our tissue the
cells are located
um and with spatial transcriptomics
finally we have this opportunity to map
the cells to our tissue like here this
example this is the
kidney
and this is normal kidney injured kidney
and
another
injured kidney and we can see that for
example our cortex is comprised of a
mixture of different cells that are
located here the glomerular
or the collecting ducts
and our
other cells for example proximal tubular
cells this third segment is located here
it's pretty much all the outer medulla
is comprised only of this type of cell
but other than organs we also can look
at for example biofilm populations
um this is the clustering of different
functions that cells individual cells in
the colony
uh
do and
use it in spatial transcriptomics it was
possible to map them to the specific
positions in the colony which allowed to
identify some hot spots for functions
for example here we can see that this
hot spot does the dendritic
denitrification
here we can see it's hot spot for high
oxidative stress and so on
of course it's not the only application
of spatial transcriptomics it's used a
lot in medicine for example in studies
of cancer because tumor is very
heterogeneous and there are different
clones some parts are evolving faster
and of course we can see some
differences in expression
also it's very useful to identify the
invasive margin of the tumor and
actually how the cells this
cancer interact with normal cells
and it was possible to build a bunch of
expression atlases for healthy organs or
the ones in disease
also in molecular biology it allowed to
localize the individual
molecules and of course study their
expression inside the cell for example
in cytosol or in nucleus
also help to understand better the
chromatin organization and cell
development
so there are different experimental
platforms
to study spatial single cell
we can separate them into microscopy
based methods like segfish ocean fish or
murfish all the hybridization based
methods and sequencing based methods for
example division
the difference is that for microscopy
based methods since it's based on
hybridization we can we have a single
cell or even single molecule resolution
and thus we can identify their locations
if it's in cytosol or nucleus or
somewhere else
um
but we're restricted to only known genes
and we cannot
study any novel ones and we also
continue lies too many genes at the same
time because we are restricted in number
of colors or they can just basically
overlap and we won't see exactly where
this molecule is
sequence and base methods are easier and
cheaper and they don't really need
a lot of pictures
made on microscop to study not the
locations
and we also can
study novel genes that we don't know the
sequence of
but it's not always a single cell
resolution and we will be focusing on
vision that is um exactly not single
cell resolution
but uh basically how vision works we
have a plate
like this and the capture area that is
comprised of small spots
and each spot already has the barcodes
the spatial barcodes that will tell us
where exactly
um this position is located so we place
our tissue above the
the capture area
and we treat it so the mrna will ligate
to our barcodes
and then we just proceed to sequence and
we get stick ones like this
so after sequencing we end up with our
metrics where we have gene counts per
cell and cell coordinates
and of course we can get some pictures
to work with as well
so um
with the data i just showed we can start
our pipeline and um
spatial transcriptomics is actually very
similar at the beginning it's very
similar to single cell analysis it also
has the preprocessing steps the
dimension reduction
uh different clustering or
algorithms and different algorithms for
cluster-specific marker gene
identification
cluster annotation
but um giotto also allows us to
uh check
to play with clusters to separate them
or to merge them based on their
similarity
um and run enrichment
and this module the spatial analysis is
what is really different and interesting
for us
um it starts with a building spatial
network and then we can uh find
spatially variable genes that have some
spatial pattern
and study coexpression and cell night
neighborhood so um i will focus only on
this part
so
um
we already did all the pre-processing
single cell analysis and ended up with
our artificial
dimensions in this case it's umapp
and we color them with laden clustering
so in this case we have 11 uh clusters
this is kidney
sample
and what is different from single cell
at this moment is that we already can
map our cells on our tissue
and we see here that for example
clusters six and seven comprise the
inner medulla and classes two and nine
comprise the outer medulla and the rest
of the classes comprise the cortex and
it's really a mixture of cells
uh what we can um
see here is for example we can plot how
many genes are expressed by which
part of our tissue and we see that
medulla is
expressing a lot more transcript than
the quarter text
so the first step in spiritual analysis
is to applaud a spatial grid or network
that will allow us to
calculate their relationships between
these parts in case of grid this is um
the expression will be summarized inside
the grid and for in case of network it
will remain as a single
cell or single spot resolution
and this allows us to run
spatial spatial gene
[Music]
search
and i wanted to show you example of two
genes snaps and gpx3 which are both
marker genes of proximal tubules
but you can see on these plots that they
actually have completely different
spatial expression patterns right we can
see gpx3 expressed in the cortex and not
expressed in the medulla and napsa is
expressed in out permedula
so
comparing it to already known um
cell types in the kidney we can see that
actually gpx3 is a
a marker gene for proximal tubules but
segments one and two which are located
in the cortex and napsa is mark
correlating with uh proximal tubules the
segment three
which is located here in the outer
medulla so spatial analysis can help us
understand marker genes better
also the next thing is spatial
coexpression
so this actually allows us to identify
the metagenes a group of genes that are
sharing same patterns of expression and
for example for this data set
this study said eight
metagenes were
were identified and here we can see
the
correlation between this g eight methyl
genes and
here are
the expression for the
metagenes on our tissue and you can see
that they all have different
patterns of expression some are specific
to inner metal some are specific to
outer metal some are specific
well not quite because the here is a
mixture of cells really but they're
specific to the cortex and we can go
from the
metagen medical gene level to single
gene level if we want to
and one more
maybe the most interesting thing is how
the cells interact and in this case um
it shows how really
well the first step is to find the
interaction changed genes so the genes
that actually in uh change
when um their expression changes when
there is interaction with different
cells
and based on these genes
we can find cell types that are
interacting within this
cluster or with other clusters
and we can say for example that clusters
4 5 8 1 and 3 they all are here
they aren't really
correlating even to each other very well
and um
for example cla
cluster 10 and 11 these are small ones
they're located here and here
they have very strong
interaction inside the cluster
and not so much with other clusters well
they interact with each other as well
so um
a spatial single cell really gives us a
lot of opportunities to study
um pretty much anywhere we can apply
single cell we can try applying switch
to a single cell and it will give us
more information at where exactly this
function
is happening and
a lot of a lot of information about
expression
patterns spatial expression patterns
so um that's it on the giotto um if you
have
any questions i think you can type them
in the qa section if there is one here
and i will move on to
amplicon
right junior
yes thank you very much for this uh
introduction to the spatial uh
uh i think we do have uh i think we do
have a couple of questions if we can
answer them okay yeah
so
um the first question is how do you
select between various manifold methods
when analyzing complex data such as
spatial single cell
so i think
yeah
yeah you want to answer take that lisa
sorry
you can take that
um no i mean um how i choose i just look
at the data i guess and see if it makes
sense or not
i would also suggest that you can use
there is no right
embedding so it's and i think it's an
important uh issue
where
it's an important uh thing to uh
remember
that you're not trying
each of those embeddings is going to be
somehow right and somehow wrong it will
preserve some of the
hidden structure of the data but it will
lose some other hidden structure so by
using many different methods you can
find
different you know sometimes it's
trajectories that you're interested in
sometimes it's clusters that you're
interested in so uh so
we always uh try to recommend
using as many
uh methods as you can to look at the
data from different sides so also such
complicated data as single cell or
spatial single cell
the umap is actually most uh if you look
at all the uh
the articles you will see that most of
the people use umap or tsne
but there are many many many more uh
embedding methods available and we
recommend to really look through at
least a few because some of them they're
based on different things and then
they also will uh reveal different
struck underlying structures of the data
so
i hope that helps
great thank you both um another question
will spatial single cell rna-seq make uh
rna single cell rna-seq
obsolete without imaging data obsolete
um can you please specify what obsolete
is i'm sorry
yeah so will
will single cell r seek without imaging
um
become irrelevant with the introduction
of spatial single cell
well um i think that there are options
when
we don't really need spatial imaging or
we can't really capture it
so
well looking at the pipeline yeah it
looks like uh all the steps we do the
same a single cell so we can
replace all the single cell projects
with spatial single cell i think that's
a good idea but still i guess there are
options when we can't really use spatial
single cells so we can
um continue working with only
just regular single cell
also if i could add to that uh
if you are using visum
then uh as lisa has mentioned you are
not actually capturing each individual
cell you are capturing a small well that
has
a few cells in it right nisa so probably
uh it at least for now
uh
single cell is still the resolution of
the single cell
rna seq is probably better than at least
this vision
and another important things for science
is a matter of
resources spatial single cell is a very
expensive technique
so
we cannot imagine that
all of our uh studies will become all of
a sudden
only single cell and only spatial single
cell
it will be just too expensive
to do science this way so for a
well-identified project you know we hear
prices
around 100 000
200 000
so not every lab
can actually afford this
actually one more thing uh julia
made a good point that
vision is not single cell resolution
there are studies when just regular
single cell and spatial single cell are
combined together so you get a spatial
information but at the same time you can
kind of get the single cell resolution
so yeah i think single cell will won't
go anywhere we'll use it
and uh if to add a little bit to that uh
you know a lot of people ask us if now
we have this technology that allows us
to do a single cell will bulk rna-seq be
absolute
and the answer is probably related
probably not
you know there are more and more
computational ways of combining single
cell data which is very sparse so you
have a lot of
genes that appear to be not expressed at
all but in reality they are expressed so
the data is very sparse and you combine
it with your bulk rna which is much more
stable but has this average cell that is
never actually exists
and you do something like the
convolution and use other uh
computational techniques to try to
connect those two together
uh so i think it's the same kind of
question
great thank you so much
all right
now
uh
no
sorry no uh i think now we will have
quine
and lisa is going to show the recorded
presentation is that correct
no no
it's a different one maybe
yours is the next one
sorry
uh can you see the screen
yeah
okay yeah um i'll speak about our
platform section for chime
and
chime is a tool that analyzes
metagenomics data this
culture-independent microbial
communities what we basically learn
about them is composition and function
of
these communities
and it can be um applied in a bunch of
areas like agriculture where you can
study soil properties or any bacteria
driven
processes in healthcare where we can
study microbiome
microbiomes of different organs
or ecology where
biosensors are developed using
metagenomics and by degradation of
plastic is also bacteria during process
and of course biotechnology the
nutrition produced or pharmaceuticals or
biofuel everything is done thanks to
bacteria
so um
basically when we sample our data and we
extract dna
um
and then we want to amplify it we can go
two ways we can either go
whole genome sequencing way or target
sequencing way and in case we want only
to sequence the target
16s
ribosomal rna is
the region that mostly is targeted in
bacteria because it has both conserved
and hypervariable regions actually there
are nine just they didn't have a picture
good enough for to include it
but this higher variable regions help us
differentiate between
um different species
so
16 as
um or
target sequencing or amplicon sequencing
it's cheap compared to whole genome
sequencing it's pretty standard we
already know all the primers so it's
easier to conduct
but it's restricted to previously known
an annotated taxa and sometimes it's not
enough to differentiate between the
samples
also we only get the compositional
information we don't know any function
that are done here
whole genome sequencing allows us to
study novel organisms and we can
assemble the reeds in
and we can run functional genomics and
understand what uh function this
organelles does
it's also more information on to
differentiate between the taxa but there
are a bunch of problems uh to hold
general sequencing of bacterias
because it's expensive it's hard to
understand what is contamination what is
not
and so on
so on the platform we um present three
modules uh pre-processing that um
consists of filtering and denoising
algorithms then we go on to taxonomy
with silver
classification filtering our classified
sequences and conducting philogenetic
trees
then we can move on to metrics to
calculate for alpha and beta diversity
so um at the very beginning we start
with the quality control and it's very
um important not to include um regions
of flow quality because they will
interfere with all the downstream
analysis with our abundances with our
phylogenetic tree and taxonomy and
everything so you have to um
understand where you want to trim your
wrists like this so you will not include
low quality nucleotides in your
downstream analysis
so after filtering the replication we
come to denoising or clustering
techniques
so the idea is that when we first
assemble our data or we have um one sec
well sequence per species or something
like that but when we run
amplification there are bound to be some
errors and we get small fractions of
sequences that are slightly different
from our original one
and when we sequence there are even more
errors and more unique sequences and so
we end up with a plethora of
unique sequences and
classics
clustering algorithms
would look for the most abundant
sequence and design it as a center
and cluster everything
that is 97 similar in one cluster
well there are a few problems with this
approach the first is that not all the
species are 97 similar some are a lot
more similar
and um
researchers came up with another
approach to noisy
which was taking into account different
models of errors and sequence same
quality calls
to try and correct
the errors the mistakes and
end up with hellotypes but these
haplotypes
are 100 similar
so after denoising or clustering um
for paired entries there is also option
to merge well not an option it's a
little step to merge the reads
um
[Music]
since
even for targeted sequencing we can pick
different size
different regions and the size of region
may
vary and sometimes the reads are
separated like this
sometimes they overlap and for example
data too treats them a bit differently
in case they overlap they only take the
part that overlaps and in case they
overhang it will take one of the reads
and
if they are separated it will
concatenate the reads together
so
when we sampled our data extracted dna
amplified it and did the noising we end
up with a table like this where we have
counts of each unique representative
sequence per sample
and here we can ask ourselves
three main questions uh first is how
similar different the things are in one
sample and that will be alpha diversity
um second question is how similar
difference are the samples between each
other that will be beta diversity
and the third is what specifically leads
to differences between the samples and
that will be a taxonomic profile and
we'll start with the third one
so for taxonomy analysis it is uh
strongly
advised to use the same primers that you
used for yours
for your
uh
data
so
the same region will be extracted from
the database um here we use silver
database that has been updated and
curated
and you can see the
mostly used primers here and primary
sequences so you just take it in
sequence add it to the platform forward
and reverse
primers
and they will extract exact regions from
the database
and run classification so it will look
for
if the sequence
is in the
silver database and it will assign
taxonomic unit to the sequences
and you will end up with a bar plot
showing
what bacteria
are there in your samples
if you want some of them removed you can
exclude them
just type the correct
name of the taxa or if maybe you want to
include just several samples so you can
do the same and you can also group the
samples based on
some categorical columns in your
metadata for example i was interested in
body sites to see if
samples from god were any different from
palms and tongue
so after taxonomy analysis
we go on to
philogenetic tree so this is
this will show how similar our
representative sequences are
and it starts from multiple sequence
alignment and then
the there are a few algorithms are
available to
build the tree fast tree and iq tree
this is mainly used for core metrics but
you can also extract the tree and
visualize it and for example fig tree or
any other tool that helps visualize
the philogenetic tree files
so after that
um
we have
looking at this table the artificial i
just came up with it to show
looking at this table we see that um
total counts for each samples are
different and
in case we can
compare sample four and sample one
they're pretty close in total counts um
we can't really compare sample 3 with
others right
so because they have different sampling
depth and we can't really run any
reliable statistics on something like
this so one of the ways out is to
subsample the frequencies
so that the total count will be the same
for all the samples like here
so we subsample
all the table and
change the table
so that the total will be the same
and
this is
not ideal because we'll lose information
um
sometimes we even lose whole samples if
their uh sampling depth is lower than
what would peak but this is a good way
to normalize your sample so the
statistics will be reliable
but how actually
should we pick the value
um
for example how did i pick 100
we should be looking at our samples and
their sampling depth now for example
here
we can see that some samples have
sampling depths lower than 1000 some
have
something depth a bit less than 2000
some are here but the majority are
having bigger sampling depth also we can
see that the number features are quite
stable starting from here so it looks
like this region
looks appropriate to take the sound and
depth
but if i
it's also very meaningful to look at
your groups and if the samples in your
groups of interests are still there for
example if i take sampling depth of 2000
my right palm sample group will be
almost will consist of only two or three
samples but if i take sampling times
1000 my right palm group will be okay i
can still work with it
the only thing that is left is core
metrics basically calculating all the
metrics for alpha and beta diversity
using the sampling depth that we just
identified
and it will give us an idea so the alpha
diversity will give us an idea how
things are inside the sample
basically telling us how rich and even
our samples with different indices
shannon index filler index
and beta diversity um will give us an
understanding how samples
are between each other
plotting pca based on different uh
distances like jakarta or
baker test and we also can run a
permanova test
on a column that we are interested in in
this case it was bodyside and
i got really good p-value meaning that
this
group has very different
beta-diversity statistics
that's it thank you very much for your
intention and uh yeah here i just is
mentioning some studies that were done
using amplicon and whole genome sequence
in mathematic genomics
thank you